what are some common myths about being a
film or television director
that you are the creative
of the you're the creative authority and
force behind stuff like the the the
myth is that the director is this genius
and the writer somehow is not
or whatever it's very clear that
the hardest thing is to come up with a
great story and the director
is then only the one who finds the best
way of telling that story and
translating it to screen
but the creative genius and i don't want
to poo poo on my fellow
fellow directors there are genius
directors out there
but the the writer is the
the one that came up with the spark and
if we're talking about creating
something out of nothing
who literally created something out of
nothing so i would say
95 of the credit should go to the writer
5 should go to the director
the math is wrong because there should
also be some for the actors and
everybody else
but it is it's weird for me to say see i
don't know how it happened maybe it's
just a personality thing that
directors tend to be more boisterous and
somehow more i don't know
grandstanding or something but how the
directors became the kings
at the alleged kings of the filmmaking
world rather than the writers i have no
idea so in that case
the the television world reflects that
the reality to me a little bit better
even where the writer clearly is the
king
and the director isn't
what about that when the director puts
themselves in the film
how do you feel about that in a
documentary setting or
always no in a narrative i have no
no strong feelings as long as
the fact that they do that doesn't
compromise the quality of the film
itself like if it's if it takes you out
of the film and i'm like oh that is
so and so then that'd be bad but if
they're a good enough actor that they
can fit in i understand the thrill
of literally putting because you're
putting so much of yourself
into that stuff anyway but it's
invisible to suddenly
break that wall and enter the world of
your film
literally and physically for a moment i
totally understand why that
is interesting it has nothing to do with
oh look at me or with an arrogance or or
something i would totally if i were a
better actor
and i could just be for a second to walk
you know through and do something i
would totally do that just out of a
juvenile thrill of you know
yeah so i have nothing nothing against
that at all
like the scene and was it staying alive
that john travolta bumps uh sylvester
stallone for one minute on the street
and you know hey yo what do you know is
this like this
quick thing but unnecessary death you
you weren't
i was in there for a split second okay
but that was only because
my voice was coming from behind the
camera throughout the film which was
important to me that i could
could change events in the moment by
actually participating in them as the
documentarian
so that then when we needed that
documentarian on screen
they would have needed my voice and my
accent and all that anyway so i was like
then i'll just do it myself
and it was so short though because
everybody else around me they're such
better actors but i am that we kept it
very very short so that doesn't take you
out of out of the whole thing
you